and so the nets go with patrick corbin
the one good thing about patrick is he's
home last four starts here 3-0 with a
very good earned run average swing and a
miss struck him out with a slider
patrick corbin's fastball is working
very well today and that's why you get
that swing and miss on that slider great
take from christian yellett she draws
the walk to allow garcia that
opportunity with two outs here's the 1-1
and
garcia hits one deep into lead field
schwarber going back and that's gone avi
garcia with a two-run blast here in the
first
it looked like he tried to come right
back in there to get that
strike on the inside part of the play
well there's your early offense
[Applause]
gave that one a ride my goodness and
that's the sixth home run of the month
for abasail garcia the brewers have a
two nothing lead after half an inning
start number 10 for freddie a 254 earned
run average big strikeout numbers hasn't
given up many hits gotta manage the
walks he walked for his last time out
against cincinnati not able to get
through the fifth two minutes away here
in the bottom of the first inning
and he sends one the other way into left
field long run yellows diving oh my
goodness he caught it
oh what a catch by christian yelich
christian yellow javale to play in the
outfield
takes a base hit potentially extra bases
away from josh bell
and peralta does indeed get that three
up and three down inning in the bottom
of the first second inning at nationals
park casting euro will lead off
swing and a miss struck him out on a
good slider down and in
and corbin has his second strikeout in
the first out here in the top of inning
number two
strike three call under the hands
patrick corbin drilling that ball to the
inside edge and his third strikeout will
bring up the pitcher the o2 swing and a
miss
wild swing of the slider he takes off
for the short hop of the ball by avila
will throw down a bell to complete the
strikeout corbin bounces back from the
first hitting start to strike out the
side of the second freddie faces kyle
schwarber to do pitch swinging in the
midst he struck him out first strikeout
for freddie peralta a little move and
little tail to it not much but just
enough starlin castro will be the hitter
castro reaching and how about that
perfectly
placed i'm not sure why willie adams
even thought about throwing that ball
and the nats have their first base hit
so now the batter is luis garcia struck
him out looking fastball outside corner
at the knees garcia knew it second
strike out of the inning for freddy and
he will face alex avila
sliders struck him out swinging good
looking pitch from freddie peralta he
strikes out the side in the second two
nothing brewers as we go to the third
something is going on with luis garcia
out behind second base
during warm-ups getting ready for the
bottom of the second he's getting a
massage on his lower hamstring area
there so there he is he's kind of
grabbing the back of his leg
and then luis just reaches down with his
glove to brace himself and goes down and
louis garcia is going to have to leave
the ball game along with his i believe
11th double of the season here's william
swing a high fly ball shallow right
toward the line soto angling over into
foul ground now he reaches back down and
makes the catch in fair territory
tagging at second going to third is long
and juan soto
i don't know if it was the wind or the
rain very nearly misplayed that into a
disaster so long at third with one away
and now here's christian yelich and the
pitch and yell it's a ground ball and
that's a fair ball down the line and
into the corner in right field gonna be
extra bases for yelling she's gonna run
a while wong will score yelich around
second he's headed at third and he's in
there with a stand-up triple grows that
brewers lead to three to nothing with an
rbi triple and yelich having a big
impact in this game with the glove and
with the bat so far so long scores
yellow stands at third still just one
away and garcia's the batter
there's garcia with the infield in no
play at the plate and the play will be
over at first so even with the infield
pulled in yelich on the move on contact
so it's an rbi ground ball for garcia
and a two run third for the brewers
four-nothing crew as we go to the bottom
of the third so now first and second for
the nationals in one out and the
dangerous juan soto coming to the plate
and there's a double play chance wong
adamus over to hiro for the double play
and the brewers go 4-6-3 and get out of
the bottom of the third inning top of
the fourth inning manny pina the catcher
facing patrick corbin
hart hit the center
andrew stevenson straight in
on a ball that was absolutely
plastered at it line drive right at you
it's always best to drop step glove side
and it's hard to really see the ball and
mike most likely was knuckling because
he hit it that hard here's kesten hira
swang
gonna miss on a heart slider down and in
patrick corbin gets hira twice that's
his fifth of the day we go to the bottom
of four so what away and schwarber the
batter
launching one
see
you
later
that's one of the longest homers ever
hit by a left-hander in this yard
and then ants are on the border fastball
elevated by peralta belt high goodbye
great swing good balance
[Applause]
you can hear it echo yup that seat right
there
third row up there 439
feet
112 on the exit velocity we go to the
bottom of five alex avila leads off for
the nets here's the one-two in a
fastball
strike three swinging for out number one
yeah it's the really good sequence that
time manny peeny goes right to the
fastball after a changeup stevenson has
half of the nationals hit total with his
two for two afternoon yadiel hernandez
will pinch it here for corbin
struck him out i don't want a fastball
for out number two they pull the slider
foul just missed the line and then goes
right back to the fastball we go to the
sixth it's a 4-1 lead for the brewery
only three hits allowed by freddie
peralta in this game trying to keep that
streak going of at least seven
strikeouts
got him looking 95 mile an hour fastball
right into the glove of manny pina six
strong from freddie peralta we go to the
seventh and if freddy can finish this
game you get credit for the complete
game
breaking ball is lifted into left field
shallow yellish for the first out of the
inning here's josh harrison
in the air to right field hit it well
garcia at the track for route number two
freddie peralta one out away alex avila
will be the hitter
and a breaking ball slapped over to shaw
and the feet of peralta and the brewers
win it
freddy peralta goes the distance
a seven inning complete game effort for
freddie peralta as the milwaukee brewers
take the opener in this split
doubleheader